grinky making his third start of the
postseason first of the alcs
he got a new decision game for the
division series against oakland giving
up four runs in four and two thirds
and that's hammered pretty deep to right
it sends back
tucker still going back and he reaches
up and makes the catch before crashing
into the wall
well struck ball by austin meadows and
tucker able to take away extra bases
boy the trajection
of that ball looked like he was gonna
ride out of here in right field maybe a
little bit of top spin
big tyler glass now on the mound for the
tampa bay rays those are his last 10
starts but it's win day when he pitches
his last 11 they've gone 11 and 0.
that'll bring up jose altuve had a home
run last night
five for 13 this postseason two homers
two rbis
and altuve hits it well and hits it deep
to left field going back to rosarena at
the wall looking up see you later
jose altuve goes deep for the second
straight day and for the third time in
this series
and it is one to nothing astros well
he's a first inning wonder these days
out 2v
in this series alone all three of those
homers have come in his first at bat
all in the first inning and the astros
get the lead runners on first and second
for altuve who homered his last time up
curveball and he spanks it to right
field
slicing away from meadows and it's going
to play it off the wall
meadows grabs it maldonado scores as
altuve bangs one off the right field
wall
and gives the astros a two to nothing
lead two they at his best when he is
using the whole field
homer to left in the first inning and
then driving that one the other way
one hopper off the right field wall here
in the third
second base runner on their first hit
meadows will be held on by guriel and up
comes randy arose arena breaking well
drilled to deep left field
back near the corner this one is gone a
home run
to tie the game he hit it into the lower
deck of the western metal supply company
and the rays
have caught the astros it's two to two
so he gets a breaking ball and a 3-1
count and crushed it continues to
befuddle my thought process as to why
they keep pitching to this guy maldonado
and he's aboard with one out
now springer will stand in one for two
and springer drives this one pretty deep
to left field ball is hooking if it
stays fair it's gone and it's gone
a home run for springer and the astros
are on top three to two
springer's first home run of the alcs
and his third this postseason boys big
swing of the bat for springer that's
huge for the astros the two-run lead
here in the fifth inning it's been a
while for springer got off to a super
hot start this postseason
but boy did he connect at a perfect time
here's mikey with the bases full of rays
as margot moves to third meadows to
second now a base hit
should be able to tie this game up swing
and a miss struck him out on a changeup
and the inning is over ray's leave him
loaded
drankie finished off the inning
stranding the base is loaded last inning
six
innings five hits two runs and now he'll
give way to christian javier
electric stuff currently out of the
astros bullpen
and you figure he's out there for
multiple innings and the slider got him
strike three his window goes down and
javier picks up his first strikeout
fastball and it's a ground ball and it
hits off the shoulder of javier and
bounces away
it's going to be an infield hit it
wasn't hit that hard but javier was spun
around after he delivered the pitch
there's a one hopper and it looked like
a hit high on the shoulder
and a base runner for the raise brings a
timer onto the plate
and he pops him up right side of the
infield foul territory guerrielle will
wait on it
in between the first base back in the
coaches boxing he makes the catch with
two hands
and that'll do it for the raise well
here is a big arm for the raise to get
back on the mound jose alvarado
he's been out with a shoulder injury
ronnie the era
gave up four runs his last time on the
mound and now he's back for the first
time this postseason is strength three
passport 99 and diaz is struck out
looking one away
now martin maldonado swing at a mess he
struck him out on maldonado and that's
back-to-back case for alvarado christian
javier's still
in worked around a two-out hit in the
seventh swing and a miss got him on the
breaking ball good slider there
to get marco trying to avoid a similar
fate tonight and
up by two a pitch swing and a miss and a
breaking ball that bounced to rosarina
down on strikes xavier has retired six
of the seven he has faced
the closer is loose he is ready but he's
still in the bullpen ryan presley javier
is going to get a third inning
one of the reasons the astros finished
two games under 500
is because they lost four games when
they were leading after eight that was
the most
in the american league 3-2 that is
outside ball four
so the rays will get the tying run of
the plate here in the ninth and
dusty baker out of the dugout that's
going to be all for javier
two plus innings of relief so it looks
like presley is going to come into this
ball game
and now the razor down to their final
out needed first base for wind on the
pitch and now the swings and drives one
toward the gap
left center field toward the wall it is
off the wall
wendell is the third base he's going to
be waved home correa gets the cut off as
adamus
slides in the second safely it's an rbi
double and it's a one run game
it's four to three tying run at third
tutugo the go ahead and run at the plate
ninth inning the one two in the air
right field
and right there to make the play is
springer ball game
the houston astros win
they have forced a game five